- So, Smartmatic has
made good on its threats
and is suing Fox News for $2.7 billion
in an epic, epic complaint.
Now, how epic is this lawsuit?
Well, let me read you one
paragraph from this complaint.
"The earth is round, two
plus two equals four,
Joe Biden and Kamala Harris
won the 2020 election
for President and Vice
President of the United States.
The election was not
stolen, rigged, or fixed.
These are facts.
They are demonstrable and irrefutable."
Them are fighting words right there.
For better or worse, this is a complaint
that was designed to garner attention.
Smartmatic is suing Fox,
Fox News, Lou Dobbs,
Maria Bartiromo, Jeanine
Pirro, Rudy Giuliani,
and Sidney Powell for
collectively $2.7 billion.
Now here's the thing: that
number is completely ridiculous.
It has no basis in fact.
It is designed to generate attention,
but attention this has generated
and Smartmatic is trying
to undo the damage to its
reputation that was brought
by all of these people.
This will go down in history as one
of the most epic complaints
you will ever see in a lawsuit.
So stick around for more
analysis and subscribe
or I'll see you in court.